so good a great here hello there reject
nation I'm Greggy I'm Johnny we're gonna
watch a video topper warts your video
Chris from Andrew Hayes whose favorite
channel was watchmojo.com Andy top 10
animated movie villains with
understandable motivations let's watch
this also known as kingpin spider-man
into the spiders not only commands
multiple super villains but he's also
smart and resourceful enough to get his
own particle accelerator built he'll
also tell anyone who gets in his way
including spider-man with the teenaged
Miles Morales witnessing the whole
affair
[Music]
it's hard not to feel some sympathy upon
discovering that he's hoping to find
other versions of his late son and wife
but the fact that he's willing to risk
the lives of everyone in New York City
by running the super collider again is
another matter but I understand his
motive we're gonna spoil the endings of
movies yeah
no spoiler alert going rose up they
don't go all that Forrest Gump the god
of the underworld hey yeah man Jimmy
Woody's a nice guy and not actually evil
from a mythological perspective at least
but I'm like you guys lounging about
this is like given the bank was not for
hollowing over and guiding this early
dad while the other gods enjoy most days
this is only up for revenge after being
excluded by his peers and isolated for
most of you the mortal existence
to get stood up baby bargains he makes
even if he sometimes uses them to his
advantage
so while his revenge certainly threatens
the Greek pantheon as well as many lives
we get why he chose such a titanic
response number 8 rex danger best so let
go to the second part let's show the
live actions all he wanted was for his
existence to be remembered
unfortunately rex crashed his spaceship
into an asteroid field and found himself
all alone and left behind a clothes
dryer
this caused rex to evolve into radical
Emmett extreme which is actually a
future version of Emmett seeking revenge
how about his name he never picked up on
extreme radical evidence it's a very
visual and trying to convince his past
self to become like him
we guess not but we can certainly blame
him for the way he went about it not
only does Rex lie about being a galaxy
defending archaeologist cowboy and
Raptor trainer but he also completes a
raptor army and pushes Emeth behind a
clothes dryer in an attempt to ensure
his future existence number seven
Captain Hook Peter Pan as a pirate
captain and possible murderer there's no
denying that hook is a villain yet his
arch enemy Peter Pan isn't much better
given his own somewhat sinister actions
like luring children away from their
families to Neverland it's a different
perspective which now pursues Hook
leaving him constantly in fear for his
life and unable to get over the trauma
of being disfigured what hands an
[ __ ]
[Music]
Hubbs pursuit of panis sympathetic even
if the man himself is not number six
Ursula the Little Mermaid
speaking of villains fond of bargains
Ursula is a sea witch who is in the
practice of creating contracts with poor
unfortunate souls including our heroine
Ariel wait those who are black
[Music]
I called satire it's mentioned that she
was cast out by oh right
Ariel's father your standards drag his
own daughter away too
so Ursula is mostly motivated by a
desire for revenge on the king who
banished her also Ursula is up front
with Ariel about what her deal entails
and it's Ariel's fault for not reading
the fine print so while this villain may
sink to murky depths we understand why
influencers getting that prize its Gabi
Gabi Toy Story 4 my name is Gabi Gabi
and this is my very good friend she a
villain would he listen to me she's a
magnet Gabi Gabi is a toy that has grown
bitter about not being wanted and it
takes out her anger on those around her
she replaced us I'm like lotsa Gabi Gabi
wasn't lost and replaced she was born
broken when a manufacturing defect left
her with a malfunctioning voice box
leaving her stock and unsold imminent I
had a similar problem decades yeah you
don't have kids are you two lost we are
looking for a lost toy well the
circumstances under which she was
created and found herself in second
chance antiques were beyond her control
the way in which he led the rest of her
life and took on several ventriloquist
dummies to do her dirty work are under
her control we can't stay
you can boys
[Music]
luckily with some guidance from woody
and his friends to change her life for
the better and can easily be paralleled
in the real world number three Shenzi
Banzai and The Lion King but not scar
[Laughter]
scar nah we can't wear the evil lion is
coming from - is there my god this is
top ten most sympathetic though
[Music]
I don't like how their faces are all
animated most expressions the wild scar
commits murder out of away to number two
Shere Khan The Jungle Book you can't
give a lion and you got pick one kids an
urbane and commanding tiger Shere Khan
is the undisputed king of the jungle and
the Jungle Book
during the course of the story he
pursues a young man cub protagonist
Mowgli relentlessly however it's
established that sheer Khan fears both
fire and Firearms both of which are
associated with men and therefore Mowgli
the tiger what's he got against the kid
Shere Khan is right to fear little
Maurice and particularly since Mowgli
ends up using fire against him
it's fine
we can understand why he would try to
head down something that could be a
serious threat to him before we get to
our most sympathetic number-one pick
because hey we kind of get it here are a
few honorable mentions we know about the
portal and we think that it's time you
sent all these monsters home th you got
onto honourable mentions
degree Lemoore his time to put an end to
the curse that I have brought upon
myself and this sucks like a burst turbo
[Music]
forgot the reserve elements
[Music]
I'm never seen not quite at the end yet
almost there though just be sure to
subscribe to our Channel and ring the
bell to be notified about our latest
videos all right back to business
number one syndrome The Incredibles a
supervillain who murders superheroes
with his killer robots syndrome is
definitely not a good guy
however he used to be mr. Incredibles
number one fan named buddy
when his hero rejected him and his
attempts at heroism it drove the young
boy to despise heroes fly home your
heroes developing everyone in his words
so that everyone can be superheroes
everyone can be super and with
everyone's super syndromes murders and
borderline sociopaths even Venice but
being let down by your hero which
Everland ever otherwise known as screen
flavor also experiences in The
Incredibles - if something a lot of us
can understand and relate to - mommy and
daddy went away because supers went away
our sweet parents were fools to put
their lives in videos wait do you agree
with her play can't wait to see the
live-action remake to watch mojo there's
no CG animated
okay that's funny Johnny haha thanks man
Thank You Phoebe for that video let's
talk about some of them one thing to
really factor in is that these are all
theatrically released movies you know
like there's a lot of DC animated
freaking started marvel phantasm hey hey
hey DC animated movies have some amazing
villains on there and this should have
been called top ten sympathetic villains
that wasn't really made clear until like
you got to scar on the Lion King because
to me scars motos make perfect sense you
know he feels like he was rightful heir
to becoming King this lion is born and
takes away his time to become King it
made sense to me but you know they gave
it to the hyenas but yeah a lot of these
come from sympathetic approaches Wilson
Fisk from spider-man into the spider
verse just wants his family back
Hades was interesting to me because I
feel like you can see that dynamic in so
many different religious texts and stuff
sure have like the God figure who casts
out one of his most trusted and and
sends them to be the lord of the
underworld and the bitterness of that
story has always kind of resonated in an
odd way or at least been fascinating to
me in an odd way especially yeah when
he's coming upon the other Titans and
he's like look where they have you
imprisoned and stuff you know well some
of the best villains
I mean excluding people like Heath
Ledger's Joker so sometimes some
villains are great just because they are
pure Anarchy or pure evil but a lot of
times the the villains we must identify
with are the ones who have been wronged
in some way like kill monger recently
you know eighties wrong in a certain way
because his brother put him there to do
this dude you know yeah yeah I feel like
there's an odd thing about villainy
where like you either have to be really
understandable or really not
understandable to the point of
monstrousness
yeah I feel like we get a lot of kind of
in the middle villains who are broody
and nastier
but you know
ultimately have kind of generic motives
I mean with Captain Hook that's an
interesting take on how well Peter Pan's
just as bad if you think about it hey
and I've never actually had a I don't
know why is I'm gonna do Andrew Dice
Clay for the rest of the video I've
never had that thought about Peter Pan
but that is true I love I got it yeah
those are the kinds of remakes I would
like to see like if you took Peter Pan
and just looked at it through different
lens and kind of had the same events
happen but then you think about it I
mean Peter Pan is whisking these
children off yeah someplace and to make
Peter Pan a villain yeah you could and
and yeah I mean Captain Hook is
dastardly but I don't know rough life I
get why he hates pan but he's still a
bad guy
yeah he's he's still bad he's chosen a
life of piracy it would be an
interesting list his top ten heroes who
are really not good that would be a
great list yeah that would be a very
fast make make that list Sher Khan I
think always makes at least I get the
logic I get how that argument forms is
like all we know about man people is
that they come in here and they poach us
and stuff yeah that ties into both the
themes of the movie basically I feel
like sure Khan goes wrong through again
a lack of sympathy yeah you know or a
critical element of humanity for lack of
a better word syndrome to me is probably
my favorite animated villain of all time
because it does everything that we kind
of jumped our commentary off with pure
evil but yet you so get it yeah and
that's that's rare to be like you I did
it both with this one guy yeah over time
you've seen his dreams get crushed and
his heroes kind of slag him off
yeah and how he is born because I mean
sure you have one I reckon are you
probably like mental problems yeah but
he is essentially born from the fact
that mr. incredible was kind of cold and
rejected him yeah things where you go ah
man if you just handle that situation a
little differently this could have all
been yeah like he's just a product of
consequence and
love that portrayal of him because he
doesn't have superpowers but when he's
on screen he is menacing there is that
this power about him oh yeah our will
yeah and the power of how much he hates
yes you know so and you see him in
action it is well that's like you wanted
to go down but yet you really get it he
really get where he's coming from it's
kind of his heart breaking journey of
this dude who you hate but also like
Kara but yes buckin is weird bizarre
it's weird really weird yeah one that is
also kind of quintessentially a comic
book thing too I think like this number
one yeah his intellect is his superpower
and he's essentially able to rise to
that level because of yeah how much of a
genius don't you kind of feel like Gaby
Gaby I like on the last three Toy Story
villains uh I feel like Gaby Gaby's the
the most sympathetic know sympathetic
because she was born with a default she
truly is a an antagonist rather than a
villain whereas the other toys just
didn't get that that's part of the toys
journey yes you're eventually not gonna
be with your owner anymore and you'll
get passed on to something else yeah
yeah they dive into villainy through
denial where she's another character
just sort of been wrong yeah yeah she's
grown up with that defect and so she's
never known the good life to have you
know yeah that's sort of losses sure I
guess out of all them yeah yeah for the
most part it's the least divisive I've
felt towards a WatchMojo list other than
I still think Skaar should have been on
the list
other than the hyenas so that everything
else I'm like now I pretty much agree
with everything they put here and hey
props to TMNT and the other honorable
mentions movies for getting on there her
TMNT was a-ok actually like TMNT and I
remember I haven't seen it but I heard
it was alright I saw it in the theaters
mmm really like a really bad reviews but
I think it was pretty cool yeah yeah I
heard it wasn't great but it was
actually all right well thanks WatchMojo
thanks Phoebe I know um there's a
featuring their faces a little bit
they're making it personal you know
they're even adding that subscribe Bell
or they wanted you to feel like the
people of watch modem hear about you and
they do and I've been manipulated into
thinking they do you can subscribe to
watchmojo.com to get some of that in
your system you can subscribe to us
click that notification bell Andrew
Hayes go check out his YouTube channel
it was his birthday recently so happy
birthday to you buddy happy birthday
everyone's August September and went to
Florida he got to go to Disneyworld got
to check out galaxies edge hell yeah he
assaulted the person playing one of the
stormtroopers hell yeah he got kicked
out put in Disneyland jail he spent
three weeks in there grew a big beard
and now he's depressed and he's slowly
morphing into a syndrome like character
no just because he thought he can get
away with touching the ass of a
stormtrooper dude you should just retire
now these are all factors in the right
place for it I want everyone to know
there's 100% truth this is what this guy
does and we just want you this isn't
really so much of a shout out as just a
warning to all the warning to look out
for integer New Jersey and you see a two
foot five inch guy with a giant beard
beard and then a Wolverine hatea where
he will grab your ass he will he will
grab you and he'll pick you up yeah he's
very similar very very attractive to
them yes see my warning yeah your heart
will flutter